a loja o pessoal que tem falou dário que
sejam muito bem vindos e mais um vídeo e
o estrago já que foi srl dói eu já tinha
jogado o primeiro strauss kahn não vamos
lá ver como é que está há tempos falando
pô
além da foto nem um chato sair dela e
sim se estou aqui e não se contentou
falar logan eo lost the beach bennett e
o ft os filhos finais imbé profeta ii eu
disse que eu tenho que ficar nos 5 noite
outra vez naquela fábrica tv pois os
jovens através do estado não entramos
agora na fábrica e hoje será um debitar
que nem só esse espaço do uso de quebra
faz florian otto caixa precisa pronto a
usar o rafinha câmera haja principio
tire fotos a itália o zé gato foi agora
que eu vou fazer eu estava mais perto
mesmo que não fosse agora eu posso comer
nenhum posso estar aqui
ai eu também penso nem o uso de gato
rosa por seu pois logo depois quase sem
operar por cima do jornal dci tirou do
armário e não quer saber onde na
primeira noite é só isto é clique do
mouse da 1 hora de escutar muito pc a
evitar que tu és tão burro tudo visto e
lido isso com atenção o cap só tanques
câmeras meu novo ler este texto por amor
de jesus cristo da nossa senhora tem
graça e não vou ler isto e o quintal e
nem dos meus temas é que o herói tem é
que várias câmeras também que um símbolo
do topo
mas gosta acho que esse património candy
né
acho que sim eu acho que é espera e
agora sai como daqui não saio não
conseguir vai conseguir ok ok aqui nós
temos então que ter atenção a candy aqui
as câmeras e tem costume de vir onde ela
está e ativar os telefones para ela ir
para mais longe e não sei que o grupo
sozinho no meu estúdio eleito china está
tudo sozinho viu o sol apareceu à porta
que desapareceu para voltar à luta o
fone tocar e não sei que não sei o que
vou fazer mas acho que o resultado não
deixa uma vez que o pai está aqui agora
que eu faço o money
ele quer que fosse uma nele e agora
espera pelo novo ou isto não só não era
só ficando cada vez que está não vai à
já não consegui tirar a câmera ao fundo
boa ela é isso é um jacques final nem
precisei duras regras demais perguntar
tudo só chegou fora e viram como ela
ficou desapareceu já que ela tá aí eu
tenho de ficar aqui nessa sala tá na
sala do oscar está outra vez agora
supostamente vai proceder a esta câmara
é isso meu eu sou chefe mowhak dos
finais mas não se esperam muitos impulso
se eu conseguir manter é quem nesta
câmara doce eu vou conseguir passar esta
noite eu nem sei que horas são aquelas
lojas alô alô nas lojas não falam nada
porque não faço com relógios um perigoso
ok é que a unita onde eu vou tocar o
telefone eu não quero saber ela tem um
filho pra cá ganhou e isso ou é muito
fácil chegar a este fato não é certo que
em x anos nossas casas as horas do ano
em cima no canto superior direito nesse
tipo de conta ou fazer vídeo ela aparece
no bar do programa e aquilo parece mesmo
em cima da hora eu não consegui ver a
hora por causa disso por isso estou
completamente fechado machado
e eu tentar decifrar a linguagem que eu
tô fora do pé
ela vai conhecer agora é exatamente mas
já devem ser tipo 3 da manhã e os punhos
não sai não conseguirá ora a lei eu
criei a tirar deste painel daqui mexe
com isso aqui no judô na outra no x
muito vai dar tudo de mim as manhas
teclas pa
ela está sem um olho no meu olho e não
nos como os olhos rasgados pato chineses
não opera ela perdeu o bochecha também
meu ela perdeu o olho porque o buchecha
e não sei o que aconteceu aquele mas
aconteceu que qualquer coisa não
acontece nada
já a amiga tinha através do relato para
o fone mil esta primeira noite é só isto
é só isso que tenho que fazer meu deus
eu tenho
após se imaginava conseguir passar a
primeira noite meu deus faz muito
barulho esta [ __ ] ou até diminuir emos
mil agora tudo isso ninguém mais faz
netflix tem ninguém de que a ação não é
do ps surge um macaco o capital é uma
fantochada nós temos que apoiar uma
chapa supostamente né
e temos também uma porta aberta é de que
o sport center mesmo que vêm da planta n
outra história é que agora então vamos
lá é por isso que eu quero é paz
histórico action embora a cara estamos
no quarto ao lado dos kings
bota um macaco é ver nada existe aqui um
macaco que ia macaca pressionou o fato é
que eles um termo macaco tem o crédito
só sei que eu preciso que não só não deu
não esquece que existe alguma coisa me
ouviam os que não tinham nenhum quadro
ou será que isso estava nos ver e não
assusta
eu não saí já eu não sei eu sei que eu
estou a preparar processos agora mesmo
eu já tô aqui com a perna cruzada já que
para controlar apoio e se ela sair daqui
disparada pelo não acho que alguém em
cima
acho que aqui estão agora não funciona
ou não funciona eu acho que lá acho é o
paa encontrei um robô maquiavélico
isso é o que resta o robocop não é o
vocal de rock news que um lugar tão
misterioso
isso não é nada eu fui contra a parede
isso não era necessário dar não vale
apenas contra a parede abraão que
enquanto jogador tipo vêm sempre um
ombro ficou sem o cinto tortura jogar ou
encontrar um chá finalmente estão no
nosso posto a gente fica controlar a
fábrica já pararam eo pc
o grande evento no twitter somos um
pequeno muito bonitinho e já protestei
até lá em cima é isso mesmo é esta porta
que eu preciso abrir a porta do carro é
meu amigo e do seu eu jô noite dois
vamos lá continuar pessoal
este vídeo vai conter a primeira ea
segunda noite porque você espera em
vídeos mais longos não é por isso embora
lá já a segunda noite e quem sabe ter
história vamos lá ver se eu passei muito
rápido eu duvido porque isto vai ser
mais difícil né não conseguir ganhar
jogos porque eu tenho coisas a frente
mas acho que é meia noite porque nós
começamos agora a gente pois ruy som já
salve qualquer coisa não olha que o usa
o que ele toca aqui não houve direito
pra que alguém bater com uma lata seu
louco é que o óquei em destaque a jesus
cristo o jesuíta toca aqui conforme
quem está aqui né há mais qualquer coisa
aqui
a diferença existe mais alguém que
esteve com um boneco já tava me leva a
uma outra vez ou outra vez meu eu estava
só explorar o jogo na minha estresse
ninguém parece que agora está no pé
esquerdo 1990 neto
eu acho o toque em cima não é que ele
está aqui por causa do fogo ae
valeu não porque porque porque nunca
vamos lá pessoal construção temos que
acompanhar o macaco é só isso que posso
fazer agora é que ele é muito fácil
controlar o que querem atacar e silva já
o cara que isso forma e agora somos a
chance de tomar café
será que ela parece que os 20 opções se
eu tenho que usar e candy implementar um
macaco
eu acho que é isso porque do lado
esquerdo e direito de se ouvir do lado
esquerdo da área que amb lado né
eu acho que isso faz todo o sentido se
for assim eu ataco macaco
acho que ela apanhou né olha eu não sei
não só eu não sei mas acho isso ela foi
uma capa buscado eu descobri eu descobri
como apanhar o macaé vai e vem e sem
limitações é a calma lá agora é só
aumentar a zona
olha uma carta diz que o outro isso vai
vai e rápido para o ataque nesta não é
isso foi aquele golzinho
acho que vai apanhar agora eu acho que
não vai apanhar agora se aproxima ao
máximo o julgamento está tranquilo só
não conseguir as horas mas já devem se
umas três peões minhas contas
eu acho que sim
othon onde a cantar aqui em cima outra
vez vai vai vai que ajuda
vamos precisar caraças muito bom muito
bom acho que kaká gato que é de
preencher meu então quer dizer que
aquele não é assim tão mau quanto isso
porque ela é o ajudam tecnicamente ajuda
né passar a noite em uma casa que agora
aqui pra baixo
op uma casa tá aqui outra vez vai sempre
aquela sala meu valor à carne mais gado
para o bege divulgado quanto foi e já se
colocar acima meu aqui é muito rápida
ainda vai levar pelas minhas contas já
venci país 55 4 da manhã eu não sei mas
acho que vai passar a noite pessoal
estômago está muito bem lá ó da história
agora tá aqui
vai que ele vai querer me apanha apanha
até macaco já conseguiu já conseguiu já
tá muito fácil muito fácil esse jogo
passa por ser eu estou sentindo o cheiro
a queimado caco hoppe o otacon outra vez
vai lá quem vai lá kenny e isso em do
menino é que no fim deste fato de que os
bichinhos que os gatos aqui o escrevi é
só achar o zé macaco a partir do momento
em que você estava em etapas e macaco
tudo torna se mais fácil graças a um tac
toca eu nunca pensei nele nesta sala me
fez um começo e desarruma vejam como
opção já tá japão gado em julgado ou
amanhã a qualificação amanhã à noite ela
foi lá ou não eu já nem sei bem que foi
agora espera ainda contar com nenhum de
falar aquele que pensar só que é
conseguir essa área é muito sério meu
baixinho época do jogo e saber espaço e
estragou o macaco um macaco o irã outro
bicho resultam sem cabeça
alguma coisa aconteceu aqui olha só o
cnmp uma lagarta que aquilo mil eu jô
apanhei precisa pagar 3 é isso não
consigo passar por ali então vamos lá
embora bank
meu deus que sons estudou
eu sei que vou para um grande susto aqui
mas eu não quer saber é o caso agora
vamos apanhar a cabeça exatamente agora
só me falta verba agora espera perna
está lá embaixo é ea itaqui perna
pessoal vamos lá no nosso estádio
já estava à espera de estudar porque dá
sustos mandar porque então é isso só
vamos ficar com espírito e espero que
vocês tenham gostado vamos ficar nesta
terça à noite se quiserem mais tempo e
nos comentários deixando voz voip e
favorito e é isso fique mãe diz
aproximam